any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so we talk about hype and i want to ask
you about artificial intelligence the
claim is that artificial intelligence is
going to eventually produce you know
artificial galileo and i've actually
worked with since i now have the text
one million words of his dialogue in
printed form now for the first time to
make the audiobook i am going to uh put
it into gpt3 and see if i can teach him
qed or you know whatever but but just
see what will come out of it because i
think it'll be interesting but
my my assumption is that
just because uh
computers can beat any human at chess it
doesn't mean they can create the game of
chess in other words uh they can't they
can solve a rubik's cube can they invent
a rubik's cube but in the essence of
physics the note the claim is that it's
just a you know max tag mark has written
about this you know it's just a matter
of time before we have artificial
finemen it doesn't matter whether the
information is processed by
carbon atoms in neurons and brains or by
some other kind of atoms in machines we
build ultimately there's no law of
physics saying
that
we are the smartest kind of
cork blobs that can possibly exist so
the bigger question is is to me is not
whether it's possible
to blow away human intelligence with
machines but just whether we will
be smart enough to figure out how to do
it and hey we just had the europe's
conference which is
sort of like the
the ai rock concert of the year which
keeps
growing exponentially in size and
it's just
quite mind-boggling how fast this field
is progressing
i'm not you know just a few years ago
robots couldn't walk properly now today
we have a viral video of
robots dancing in the new year at boston
dynamics
not long ago you know we didn't have
self-driving cars now we have
self-landing rockets thanks to elon and
not long ago
we didn't have machines that could even
beat us at the asian board game of go
and now just the other week google deep
mind came out with the latest the mu
zero
which not only crushes us to go and
chess
and japanese chess shogi but also in all
the atari games from the old times
pretty much without even being told the
rules so things are happening fast do
you know what einstein called the
happiest thought of his life not fantasy
but the happiest thought of his life
lawrence i i seem to remember it but
remind me as a no sense is that if you
were in free fall you'd experience zero
exactly yeah yeah yeah
gravity would be uh
he called that the hat now how can a
computer and that's what led to gr you
know in some sense
um how can a computer a know what it
feels to free fall b
know what uh know what happiness is in
this context and c how can they take
that intellectual leap if you're just
taking data from newton and showed the
perihelion of mercury anomalously
advances how would you possibly get from
that you know lacunae in the data to a
new way of thinking about a fundamental
force so those are my opinions what do
you think about i think i think you're
being short-sighted but i also think
these other people are being ridiculous
i mean first of all anytime you hear
people predict things about things we
don't know anything about
they call themselves futurists often
that's when those are people you
shouldn't listen to
um and almost invariably they miss the
important stuff
i mean we were supposed to be in flying
cars and you know when in the 1950s but
when they talked about 2000 but they
didn't talk about the internet
well first of all we don't even know
what intelligence is in some deep sense
but but you're making the assumptions
that you know i can't input all of the
um
the sensory uh
data input that you would feel in free
fall and and for me
i see no barriers
ultimately
to
what you would call it an artificial
consciousness but it's not the problem
with artificial intelligence is not
artificial in any sense it's it's
creating a an electronic version of a
system that arrives haphazardly by
biology and and and biology did it very
effectively because it had a long time
to do it um
so i don't see any barriers to
ultimately
what you would call computers being
conscious i i ultimately don't see
computer finding is not the way of
putting it but what i i
am interested in a general artificial
intelligence in in in those using those
language which i don't like um
precisely for the same reason i think
that feynman was
which is
i would like to know
what
an intelligent computer what physics
questions an intelligent computer would
find interesting
and
there's not it's not at all clear to me
that they'd be the same questions it's
to me it's just like wanting to know
about an alien intelligence
i would love to have an alien
intelligence so i'd like to learn a lot
about what they've learned about the
world and how they think about it
because it would illuminate presumably
potentially a completely different way
of thinking about the world than i'm
used to
if we allow data to come in we will
discover something new okay so the
self-fulfilling prophecy is if you don't
search you will never find
and on the other hand
if we do search we will find something
and i believe that within my lifetime
there is a chance
that we will get our hands on a
technological relic from another
civilization and that would be amazing
so i have something to wait for
not the response of my colleagues not
uh
flattery from people around me
um rather
allowing nature to give me
uh new knowledge by
looking at it
and that's all and i don't need anything
more than that
so i don't
see it as a say a threat in that sense
nor do i see it as a panacea i see it i
think in the long run is kind of
inevitable but not in any but i mean
long run i don't think all
ai is an area that's incredibly hyped
you're absolutely right computers can
feed people at chess but they can't but
robots can't yet really effectively fold
laundry um and and so um you know this
notion of you know
around the corner
that's going to happen i think it's
ridiculous i find it fascinating that
plato and others going back to plato and
in full circle
around the time that writing was first
invented
totally decried writing because they
said it would ruin storytelling
storytelling would be over because
people wouldn't have memories they
wouldn't be able to do this stuff and of
course it didn't happen and as
computational systems become more
capable in different areas
it will change things but i don't see
um
i i guess i don't see the same beer i
think you're just imposing the present
on the future
who knows what the origins of creativity
is except it's making connections at
some level between disparate things in
some way i don't see any barrier
ultimately to a computer with sufficient
sent input from a variety of things to
be able to not understand
what
what it how happy it is to fall in the
absence of gravity that we feel pain
in the everywhere we feel pain in the
brain
okay
not the fingers not when not the ones
that are being burned it's in the brain
that it's created and and it's and it's
created because of a whole bunch of
biochemical reactions that relate to
sensory input and i don't see that
electrochemical reactions or electrical
reactions
related to similar sensory input can't
create the same feelings in that
artificial brain but it's this
fundamental physical philosophical
question which none of us can ever
really answer which is how do i know
that your pain is the same as my pain
how do i know that you're green even
though i'm colorblind that your green is
the same as migraines
[Music]